how can you start a business without
money I got a great question from one of
my youtube viewers love you guys Paul
who wrote in to say how can you start a
business without money this is a great
question because a lot of entrepreneurs
do one of two things a lot of
entrepreneurs don't start because they
feel like I don't have enough money to
start a business so I'm not going to
start and they let that limiting
negative person believe hold them back
and then other entrepreneurs go and they
spend whatever money they have to start
their business and they end up not
succeeding you end up you know if you're
making t-shirts you buy a thousand
t-shirts and they just sit in your
closet they sit in your garage and you
have this inventory just sitting around
not making you any money here's the key
okay here's how you start a business
without making money you start around a
service the reason why service is so
important to get started is because it
gets you close to your customers it
brings money coming in to your door so
you can put food on the table so you
have to worry about going back and get
another job and it means you don't have
to start with a lot of startup expenses
okay you don't need to have an office I
don't want you to go out and spend money
in an office spend money on business
cards spend money on a website spend
money on brochures just start talking to
people let them know what you do let
them know that you can help see if
there's a way that you can help out
companies that are already in your
network you're starting around a service
if your longer-term vision is I want to
have this product you don't want to just
trade my time for money that's okay but
start with the service because it gets
you really close to the customers it
helps you understand their needs it
helps bring money in the door and then
you can build a product to leverage your
time and when you do that you have an
expertise base you have a customer base
you can sell them your product too but
the way to get started at the very
beginning is not to spend money you
don't have to spend money to make money
you just have to get out there and start
talking to your ideal customers let them
know what you're all about
children you can help them and work on a
small project okay when you're working
with your first customer if you don't
have a lot of experience a lot of
background
if you're coming in with a big pitch a
big expensive pitch it's risky
they're probably going to say no there's
a lot of people that they may need to
talk to just find one simple small thing
that you can do to help them whatever
their biggest pain point is just one
little thing that you can work on and
then over deliver like crazy so you
don't have to write a proposal you don't
have to make a sales pitch you're
helping them with one small thing and if
you over deliver like crazy you want
them saying wow that guy was so good
I wonder there's anything else that you
did help us out with and you're in and
you're going to get more deals and more
deals on more deals and you can increase
your prices and then you can launch new
products but the way to get started is
to start a service and don't spend money
until you're making money believe who's
been watching like the video give it a
thumbs up below let me know what you
think
leave a comment ask the question bill in
the comment section and click on my face
to subscribe to the channel thank you
guys so much I'll see you soon